more than 1.5 billion people around the
world
over half of them under the age of 24
regularly watch
short videos clips of 60 seconds or less
using snapchat tick-tock instagram
stories
and other smartphone apps the market
barely existed 7 years ago
yet today creators are uploading 702
million short videos every day as our
attention span is falling to seconds
short video is not only here to stay but
will become the new normal
unlike other social platforms such as
instagram where perfectly edited
polished images are the norm short
videos are more
accessible inviting imperfection and
authenticity
and because each clip is so short
content producers
have to be creative and concise
communicators
but these bi-sized videos are more than
just fun
and entertainment for me personally
as a consultant and mother short videos
are where i get parenting tips
on my way to work i can quickly learn
about the secrets of breastfeeding while
traveling
and get great ideas about how to make my
daughter sleep sooner
businesses are also learning that short
videos
is a great way to find new customers
and expand the diversity of the
audiences
earlier this year i led a project with
tick-tock
the world's leading short video platform
to assess the economic and social
impact of this bite-sized economy
our study shows that this young medium
is changing a lot more
than the way we spend our leisure time
in 2019
short video generated an estimated 95
billion us dollars
in goods and services sold and created
roughly 1.2 million jobs globally
even within this short lifespan short
video
is already impacting the way we work
communicate
and learn in the age of covet 19
while museums around the world are
facing indefinite closure
many have acted quickly to bring in
and engage a new younger audience
remotely
the official gallery in florence which
just established its official new
website three years ago
is using short video to attract new
audiences
to their statues and paintings by
matching exhibits with emojis
music lyrics or funny quotes the museum
is making its artwork
more accessible and relevant to the
young generation of art lovers
in one of its recent posts a cartoon
coronavirus
turned into a rock and smashed in half
in front of caravaggio's painting medusa
who has the power to turn those who gaze
at her into stone
corona very
ufc also experimented with influencers
live streaming
from the gallery on short video platform
allowing viewers around the world to
experience
art that they've never been able to see
in person
since its appearance on tick tock in
april 2020
the museum's profile has attracted more
than
43 thousand followers in three months
the speed is far quicker than their
journey on twitter
where it built up similar number of
fanbase using the past four years
small businesses are also using short
video
as a way to find new audiences who might
have never heard of them
or their products before in 2018
though in the leading chinese short
video platform
as part of its social responsibility
initiative to alleviate poverty in china
launched a campaign to help individual
farmers and small businesses
in china's mountainous areas cell phone
produce
as one of its pilot projects del in
invited content producers
to create four pieces of 15 second short
videos
showcasing the quality of their products
this is on top of other regular pr
initiatives such as promotional articles
though inc wanted to leverage the large
user base of short video
to find those customers who might be
interested in those products
and then connected them with the
e-commerce website
so that people can buy things as they
watch the videos
in just five days the initiative helped
nearly 4 000
families in citroen province sell an
astonishing 120 000 kilograms of plums
many brands that are interested in
hiring and recruiting young people
have been using short video as a fresh
way to engage with generation z
for example more than half of mcdonald's
employees are aged between 16
to 24. in australia
the brand was struggling to recruit in
recent years
so it launched something called snap
application
which is a snapchat lens that enabled
users to shoot
10 second videos explaining why they'd
be a perfect mcdonald employee
and then prompt them to link up job
application within 24 hours after
launching the campaign
mcdonald received 3 thousand
applications
4 times more than the number they
received in the whole week
using traditional methods while it's
unclear whether hiring over short video
is the best way to find the right people
for the job
or to retain talent but judging solely
from recruiting numbers
the campaign was a global hit in saudi
arabia
mcdonald received 43 000 applications
within 24 hours
and the company launched the campaign
again later in the us
much like how i like to get parenting
tips from short videos
many users also want to leverage the
platform to learn
but in tiny bite-sized doses
in our study short video users globally
rank the top benefits of the platform as
discovering new interests and learning
new skills
in emerging market especially short
video for learning and education
has huge potential to change the status
quo
in 2019 tick tock launched a campaign in
india with the aim of democratizing
learning for the indian digital
community
while the app has been banned in the
country since july 2020
it launched a huge demand for
educational short video content
and other platforms are jumping in to
fill in the space
tiktok was able to spark this trend by
collaborating with
indian social enterprises education
startups
and popular creators to produce 15
second short videos
that cover a range of topics from school
level science
to learning new languages as the first
wave of short video became widely spread
on platform
audiences got inspired and some even
began to create their own
educational content by october 2019
the campaign had generated more than 10
million videos
and garnered 48 billion views
through helping people learn and
participate into the process of content
creation
short videos are in fact helping prep
and train the skilled population
that can take on the challenges of the
future
like all social media there are valid
concerns around short video platforms
including data privacy the addictive
nature of the format
and the lack of nuance and context in
the content
however i still think that the positive
outcomes of short video
will outweigh its downsize i believe
short video will become a more vital
economic
and social force in the future it is
precisely because of this
that we need to find the right way to
benefit
from this young media through
collaboration among users
platforms and policy makers
thank you